- On n'est pas un petit peuple,
on est peut-être quelque chose
comme un grand peuple!
(acclamations)
- René Lévesque
est incontestablement
une des figures politiques
québécoise les plus marquantes
de notre époque. Et pourtant,
le connaît-on si bien?
MARC TESSIER, éditeur,
scénariste et photographe
- En faisant ma recherche
René Lévesque, je le connaissais
pas, puis je suis comme...
je dirais pas tombé en amour
avec lui, mais il m'a frappé
dans ses valeurs, dans ce
qu'il était, puis j'ai trouvé ça
incroyable et fantastique!
- Le scénariste Marc Tessier,
s'est entouré de 13 jeunes
illustrateurs pour raconteren 1n
exceptionnel de René Lévesque.
- J'ai essayé de prendre
les vraies paroles de René
Lévesque, puis de faire
un espun espun espèce de collage
pour que ce soit lui que
les gens entendent, pas moi, là,
René Lévesque.
- Sa lutte pour
ionalisation
de l'hydroélectricité au sein
du gouvernement de Lesage,
l'élection du PQ en 1976
ou encore, la nuit des lon
couteaux, un artiste différent
illustre chacun de ces chapitres
de sa vie.
JORDANNE MAYNARD, illustratrice
- Il y avait façon aussi
de présenter ça sous un aspect
documentaire, puis le dessin, en
fait, permet j'ai l'impression
de rendre ça plus... bien
justemjustemjustemjustement plus
de rajouter un brin d'humour
aussi, on va se le dire.
- "Quelque chose comme
un grand homme" raconte aussi
des épisodes moins connus comme
lorsqu'en 1945, il a constaté de
'horreur du camp des mort
à Dachau ou encore son passage
à Radio-Canada marqué par
la guerre de Corée, la grève
des réalisateurs de Radio-Canada
ou son émission phare :
"Point de mire".
- On dit qu'Expo 67 a ouvert
le Québec sur le monde, mais
je pense que "Point de mir
était là avant pour préparer
le terrain, puis moi, c'est
quelque chose que j'admire
beaucoup, cette espèce
d'ouverture sur le monde en
construisant des bases solides
pour notre société québécoise.
JULIEN POITRAS, président, C. A.
éditioGraphique
- René Lévesque est présenté
avec ses qualités et ses défauts
à l'intérieur de ce projet-là,
avec ses succès et ses échecs
également. Donc ça nous fait
également à mon sens prendre
conscience de toute la fragilité
de cet homme-là.
- Une invitation pour les jeunes
et moins jeunes à ré-enchanter
la politique.
- Si ça peut permettre aux gens
de s'intéresser davantage
à la politique, puis de se dire:
ah bien oui, nos politiciens
peuvent travailler dans le bons.
- La BD "Quelque chose comme
un grand homme" est un récit
captivant, qui nous permet
de nour un personnage
incontournable et tout un pan
de notre histoire.
Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
Radio-Canada, M